The Joe Rogan Experience the wildest one
is religion go on that they're tax-free
oh the amount of money impossible like
Joel Osteen is raking in tax-free does
he have to pay any taxes does he have to
personally pay taxes how does that work
if I actually have no idea find out
believe that you're limited salary if
you if the if your church is
incorporated but having churches pay no
taxes is wild but that speaks to
stability where it's like it's the it's
kahoot stability it's like the the Bill
of Rights and the Ten Commandments
they're not exactly one-to-one but it's
all kind of the there's no coincidence
there where it's like everything that
that it's another wing of the it's a
I've I've used to refer to God as super
cup
we can't be there
but you shout out steel you shall not
even if there's no cameras don't steal
his nuts because the Scientology got it
oh yeah yeah yeah yeah they they sued
they sued the federal government and
they got tax exempt status
and uh you know that's wild because you
know the guy who wrote it like yeah one
specific guy who is the not just the
most he's the most prolific author in
human history you know that he published
more works of fiction but not that that
was all real no no I mean that's what
you guys got to take the day off and
they get no taxes it's pretty wild I
mean if you're like a small Lutheran
Church and you you know you serve the
community and you put on Charities and
do a bunch of great things and you're
like a real asset yeah there's a lot of
those churches and they should be
tax-exempt I don't other than like the
sea org slave [ __ ] I don't care about
scientology do you know what I mean like
I don't think that they're they charge
for classes I don't know they they kind
of make you give them a tithe at
churches seems like it's working out for
Tom Cruise it's working out for a lot of
them so really working out that's why
I'm saying like I don't care
just don't put people's don't Slave
people don't do that don't kidnap Kelly
miscavige and all that [ __ ] but like the
rest of it I don't care about the rest
of it's not any different to me than any
other religion it seems like it's real
similar to what goes on in a lot of
religions in a sense because there's a
lot of religions that force people to
work as missionaries there's a lot of
religions that you know ask things of
people and you have to tithe ten percent
and have kids and don't use birth
control I'm like that's pretty
significant that's very significant yeah
yeah and there's gay people yeah yeah
there's a lot of weird stuff from
religions that we just accept
yeah but didn't you say that um I think
you said this that when you had a
psychedelic experience you kind of
stopped being an atheist yeah it was I
was an atheist and then
Ayahuasca Journey number four
no Journey number three
oh I'm in the president guy
um I'm just in it now and it's not
they I mean again this is what I
experienced so it's not
true or false but
um
it's a that's a central creation for us
that I experienced there was you know it
didn't it didn't have any rules or laws
or did you get a sense of what this
whole thing is supposed to be like what
are we doing like if if there's a
central creation force and you interact
with it like what is it what does it
want what does it want from us and what
is it doing with like life
I my experience this was from the bufo
not Ayahuasca which I is amazing bufo's
just too rough for me
uh I I was drowning on
incomprehensibility
I don't think it's comprehensible what
the purpose
is
my that's my experience I don't I didn't
even get love from it
I didn't get paid I didn't get venom
yeah I just got indifference I just got
like super powerful just power force
yeah just force it felt magnetic in a
weird way so is bufo five methoxy
yeah that is a very different feeling
that's a very different uh experience
that that one I really thought I was
gone I thought I died I mean it dude I
didn't even when I was here last time I
wasn't totally yeah recovered I feel
like there's some sort of trend
um in life and in in the cosmos of
things getting more complex and you know
I'm not the first person to ever point
this out either
um but with human beings in particular
everything is about technological
innovation and things becoming more more
complexed and information being more and
more accessible and being more and more
connected with each other it seems like
a really really obvious trend
and if you play that Trend out
you know a thousand years a hundred
thousand years a million years like
where where is that going is that going
on all over the universe and is that
what God's doing is God all about this
constant state of improvement that it
goes on forever until you reach like
literally like a god-like being yeah
yeah that's the thing
with with uh I I had a few
kind of rapture
experience like ish rapture-ish
I just get the feeling that if if like
when if there was a Rapture or whatever
I just think people will go wow this was
we [ __ ] were really worried about the
wrong [ __ ]
for sure like Beyond even our comprehend
like
so far past what we were like not even
worried about
uh [ __ ] or war or any of that stuff
it's like dude it's just about this
energy
field that
I couldn't make heads or tails of in
terms of like we're supposed to well if
you think of amoebas if you think a
single-celled organisms they eventually
become multi-celled organisms they they
develop the ability to move around and
they they come on Shore and they evolve
and change and this goes on forever and
ever and ever and then one day in 2022
they're us that's what we are we're the
most advanced form that we're aware of
of that thing if that keeps going
maybe that is what creates the universe
itself maybe the universe is making
itself through us we're just in this
amoeba stage and we can't even
comprehend it with to us it's like what
are you talking about we're going to
change the world like imagine an amoeba
being born in the bottom of a volcano
Silo you know on the bottom of the ocean
I felt like an amoeba on on 5mm yeah
well you basically probably are I think
we probably all are a version of that in
comparison to this ultimate thing that
we're going to become if if we do keep
evolving If evolution is a real thing
and it did go from single-celled
organisms to what we see now in human
beings if you just keep going that
should that should get to some place of
impossible
energy and power and maybe the universe
itself like maybe that's what it's made
out of maybe that's how we make things
like stars and maybe the universe itself
is born out of this and we're just this
really tiny stage this amoeba-like stage
that will ultimately become the god
force of the universe maybe that's our
ultimate transition between a physical
being into this thing of energy and love
and light and power and and in in
indifference in many ways to our own
plights because it's it's necessary to
achieve this purpose like all of our
[ __ ] and maybe all of our struggles
maybe all of our debates about things
and trying to figure out what's white
and what's wrong whose philosophy is
correct and whose behavior is correct
maybe all of that is just trying to get
us to that ultimate stage where we're
going to be and that's what happens
everywhere in the universe that's the
universe creating itself everywhere all
over the place when things get and they
have a certain amount of troubles that
they have to deal with with whether it's
Tribal invasions or super volcanoes and
figure it out get to a point where you
can become the next thing
yeah I mean on and on and on and on and
on forever yeah I mean that's I would if
my especially my I mean my 5meo
experience was about having no sense of
order whatsoever meaning I was an amoeba
I didn't know what breathing was I don't
know what direction was I don't know
what sight was I didn't know [ __ ]
anything yeah and I was I was drowning
on I don't know any I don't know what a
thought is
it was really incredibly different like
it's hard Beyond and so that's what I've
come away from one of the things I've
Come Away with from it with is is this
sense of like we're just trying to order
things more than anything like that's
our number one sort of human priority
because it's like the best way to
survive yeah and I feel like we're
ordering for the wrong stuff a lot of
the time but it's inevitable